[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
danville lecture d'un teddy wolf faujour
triste car oui pourquoi vous avez le
sourire parce qu'on va parler d'un livre
qui vous a donné la pêche comme disait
alain juppé c'est trop jeune pour être
vieille de jeune gourou pour joël
bourgeot merci des jeunes pourraient
être concernés avec ça on s'y prend
jamais trop tôt vous préparez vous
préparez un peu pour préparer cet âge là
alors on peut on peut dire en deux mots
qui est joëlle goron pour ceux qui ne la
connaîtraient pas encore et on va quand
même vous présente quand même alors vous
avez pour joëlle goron collaboré à de
nombreuses émissions de télévision de
radio et on retient notamment et bien
vos chroniques aux côtés de christine
bravo dans la fameuse émission france
dans les années 1990 puis aussi le fou
du roi sur inter à la bonne heure sur
rtl vous êtes scénariste scénariste et
réalisatrice de films pour la télévision
et le cinéma parmi nombreux scenarii on
peut retenir le clan pasquier ou encore
ceux qui sont écrits pour les enquêtes
du commissaire maigret
quand on voit ce qui est formidable et
vous est également l'auteur de plusieurs
livres je râle pour vous le poulet du
dimanche pour ne citer que ceux-là on
retrouve aujourd'hui est bien avec trop
jeune pour être vieille petit manuel de
savoir rire et profiter de son âme
co écrit avec delphine apiou donc je
dirais que c'est un manuel tout à fait à
votre image à l'image de votre joie de
vivre de votre liberté de votre
franc-parler
un livre très drôle patrice est ce que
tu peux nous en dire un mot justement
c'est ce livre là c'est vrai que vous on
vous reconnaît évidemment à travers ses
fans c'est au fond l'idée quand même
qu'on peut être vu dieu puisque c'est
son nom sa part tout en étant ouvert
positive
et vive encore oui parce qu'on est dans
une année dans une société où les choses
sont très lourdes du côté de l'aj en
particulier pour les femmes c'est aussi
bien dans le domaine professionnel où on
déclare très vite à quelqu'un qui à 50
ans à une femme qu'à 50 ans oui vous
êtes un peu un peu je préférerais
quelqu'un de plus jeune enfin bon donc
là ça joue et puis une société ou d'un
autre côté on vous impose aussi le fait
qu'il faut être pétillante joly à
l'image des stars qu'on nous montre
aussi bien dans les magazines que qu'au
cinéma
et puis on est quand même dans cette
société où on est à la fois il faut être
jeune mais on et deviennent de plus en
plus tôt il va falloir et constant
travailler avec une retraite jusqu'à un
certain âge qui fait que tout ça rend
les femmes un peu schizophrène justement
comment comment vous expliquer cette
schizophrénie parce que c'est vrai qu'au
tour voilà on vit plus de noms mais plus
longtemps et en même temps d'aller y
admire ce qu'ils vous disent à 27 50 ans
un peu plus la regarder
doc est bien différente de la réalité
sociale
c'est là que vivent les femmes c'est
concret pour l'expliquer ça comment
l'expliquer parce que la société a
vraiment tout a vraiment bougé d'abord
prônons même sur le plan on peut dire un
peu sociologique c'est à dire qu'est ce
qui se passe quand la femme arrive vers
les 50 ans ja il ya tout qui lui tombe
sur la tête en fait il ya la ménopause
ya les enfants qui sont vont genre de
truc qu'on prend plus ou moins bien et
il ya on devient le pivot de la famille
sociologiquement c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire dans notre histoire
c'est à dire que on est à un âge vers
les 50 60 ans ou à la fois on a des
grands enfants qui se retrouvent
éventuellement dans des situations
pécuniaire difficile à cause des
problèmes de chômage et tout ça on a des
parents qui ne sont à la fois pas 6 h
cie ag que ça mais qui peuvent être
malades c'est à dire mon et responsable
tout un exode de des deux côtés et tout
ça fait que c'est très pesant et d'un
autre côté c'est ça qui est curieux
c'est que jamais
la femme n'a bénéficié d'autant de
choses c'est à dire moi j'appelle ça les
réparable par tous les bouts on est
réparé a pendant que d'avoir des
lentilles on peut avoir
on entend moins bien on a des appareils
fait les dents c'est super je ne parle
pas de chirurgie esthétique vous
entendez un peu dans le giron c'est
parce que je pense que c'est le problème
de chacun
et moi je préfère qu'on dise c'est une
belle vieille que la cie les femmes qui
manque qui va faire passer pour 35
je ne veux pas passer pour 35 ans vous
parlez du marais qui dit je t'aime comme
tu es vous y croyez sans nom franchement
quand le mari vous dit vous dites oh là
là est ce que je peux sortir comme ça et
je t'aime comme tu me croyez pas parce
que c'est pareil mais n'empêche que lui
vous vois qu'il vous voit pas vieillir
c'est vrai je ne vois pas de l'oublier
au sein de la patrie on va et vient des
coups aux sauvegardes ou sap avait pas
de l'avant voilà mais alors où on a
l'impression à vous lire quand même
kemer donc ces nouvelles vieille comme
vous les appelez c'est plus la lame
aimait bien rangés dans le mans et lens
et qui cette nouvelle vieille chaussette
nouvelle vieille comme la barre est à la
fois ça c'est pas vraiment cette cette
femme 50 60 65 ans et tous elle sait pas
elle a pas de référence alors elle elle
sait pas comment s'habiller mais elle
tente des choses alors parfois elle se
dit voilà est-ce que je peux mettre ça
encore à l'âge que j'ai d'un autre côté
elle n'a pas envie de mettre la blouse à
fleurs de sa grand-mère qui poussait une
brouette envers lui dire c'est pas la
même c'est pas la même femme
c'est une femme qui a travaillé c'est
une femme qui a eu des copines qui a eu
des copains tout ça a fait que mais d'un
autre côté elle n'ose pas elle sait pas
et la société qu'elle a par dessus donc
la seule solution c'est la solution ne
viendra pas de l'état jeudi à un moment
je m'embarque dans un grand réseau n'en
met prenons l'exemple la différence de
salaire entre les hommes et les femmes
un qui a été je me souviens les premiers
papiers que je faisais c'était un grand
copain de votre force
c'était incroyable de cette différence
elle était plus 30% aujourd'hui elle est
de 19 pour cent a fallu trente ans pour
cette petite différence
donc il n'ya pas c'est pas l'état qui va
changer les choses c'est nous
individuellement prenons nous en main et
devenons des nouvelles vieille c'est à
dire
servons nous de tout ce qui existe à
notre portée et poussons nous aux fesses
parce qu'il ne faut pas cacher les
choses c'est pas on n'est pas heureux
d'être vieux leur recton ce discours à
la con qui veut faire croire que c'est
un formidable la gnagna non non tout
n'est pas formidable
il faut arriver à un moment à faire une
juste juste situation entre les choses
qu'on va abandonner petit à petit et les
autres où il faut se poussé aux fesses
parce que il ya des choses dont 10 en
sont naturistes plus alors je laisse
tomber j'ai peur mais ça vous le dit
très bien ça émouvant j'ai poussé un
étouffement sur cinq ans je ne lâcherai
pas il ya les choses ne faut pas lâcher
et puis il ya les choses nous faut
lâcher parce que d'abord toutes les
choses qui vous emmerder tout au long de
vos nuits
la chaire est par exemple de dire ce que
le nombre de fois où je n'avais pas dit
ce que vous pensez vous justement c'est
sous des mots poser une question là
dessus parce que vous avez fait beaucoup
d'émissions avec des auteurs avec des
acteurs des actrices parfois qui vous
gonfler quoi il ya un moment où vous le
disiez papier un moment vous êtes lâchés
et guettent la liberté quand même ça ça
ça vit aussi avec l'âge comme très
important c'est très important à un
moment de se dire mais je pense quoi
pour de vrai ya quelqu'un qui est en
train de vous raconter un truc
d'habitude vous êtes police sur elia qui
salue tous les pays à un moment et puis
les rapports professionnels qui fait que
qui font qu une fois ménagé les choses
mais le moment où vous où vous ne
travaillez plus où vous avez décidez
vous avez
vous êtes au moment de la retraite et où
vous allez pouvoir être vous même et
c'est une chose mais qui est éclatante
au restaurant par exemple le type qui
s'approche et qui vous demande le
serveur qui vous dit alors c'était bon
madame cependant et ben non je suis pas
le seul à franchir vie par rosa
ressemble à rien vous pouvez on peut le
dire gentiment moi je sais pas dire les
choses gentiment quand j allais vous y
allez vous mais j'ai passé des années de
ma vie c'est vrai ou aussi bien
professionnellement dans les rires ah ah
rien dire ça vaut pas le coup aussi l'un
des courts mais il s'avance pas le très
bon mais lucho fou quoi voilà là on dit
et et c'est un bonheur
on se reconnaît
on se dit mais en fait qui est agitée
comme ça mais pour que j'ai passé ma vie
à fermer ma gueule voilà vous avez quand
même un franc parler est ce qu'on peut
dire au fond que votre manuel de savoir
vieillir c'est quand même une aide à la
digestion c'est ce qu'on était en train
de dire vous l'avez dit puis apprendre à
prendre de la distance avec soi même
quand on vous lit on a l'impression
qu'au fond apprendre à vieillir c'est
aussi apprendre à ne pas se prendre au
sérieux la mettre l'humain au centre des
choses au centre de la vie vous avez dit
dans votre clip je peux le dire que vous
avez 77 ans alors comment vous
personnellement vous fait pour rester
toujours aussi aussi vive
non je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'on revoie c'est comme si on était une
caméra pendant des années on a vu les
choses venir d'une version et petit à
petit on se dit on avec ses propres
c'est sa propre revue et avec surtout
une chose c'est lire ce livre qui est je
crois je sais pas moi de le dire mais je
crois qu'il est assez drôle et très
c'est très drôle et très positif et
voilà politique parce que je pense que
surtout je pars toujours d'exemples
réels c'est à dire
dans la vérité je suis quelqu'un qu'elle
les pieds sur terre je suis pas
l'humoriste guy qu'on vous avez écrit je
pars toujours les choses vraies et
surtout regarder ça à le à l'aune du bon
sens se dire j'ai toujours fait ça comme
ça mais le monde pour de vrai
qu est ce que je devrais faire et ça ça
change tout alors évidemment ce qu'il ya
derrière
je lave où cette espèce d'énergie qu'il
faut avoir ça c'est pour cette volonté
est plus dur ça c'est très dur d'abord
parce que c'est un partage inégal de la
façon d'un même façon il ya des femmes
aux yeux bleus aux yeux verts des petits
des grands des belles des moches elle
fait savoir
c'est inné la vie est inégale et
l'énergie c'est quelque chose de très
inégale moi j'ai été bien pourvus je
crois que j'avais un truc mais n'empêche
je suis beaucoup moins énervé j'exerce à
se stimuler l'énergie les élus manche
donne un exemple par exemple avec les
maris le mari souvent au moment de la
retraite
s'il n'a pas eu des passions très
personnelle une aimantation extérieur
c'est un homme qui va se retrouver
affalé sur le canapé
il sait plus quoi faire in happy night
dont le talent et toute la journée
devant la télé parce que c'est c'est eh
il avait une petite entreprise
il était dans un boulot il est habitué à
commander ils décidèrent tout d'un coup
là il s'est plu donc là par exemple
cette énergie c'est la femme qui doit
l'avoir et je dirais que la femme à ce
moment là elle est l'animatrice
c'est à dire c'est elle qui va dire vous
dites à votre mari on irait bien cet été
en espagne et deux aux soleurois
bougeait pas très envie alors vous allez
le manager vous allez montrer un film
sur les stades
non tout simplement
jeudi l'animatrice et ça c'est une
fonction très féminine
j'avais une chose sur laquelle jouent
comme vous interrogez puisque will et de
tout à l'heure de l'égalité des salaires
c'est vrai que vous êtes féministe vous
avez oui tant est qu'on arrive il ya ce
néo féminisme qu'on voit aujourd'hui
genre alice coffin qui dit ben j'ai
arrêté j'ai pas de mecs comme 8 d'être
d'être violée d'être bâti etc
qu'est-ce qui est ce que si facile du
mal avec ça avait un peu de mal oui je
lol mais bien sûr que comme j'entends
tout ce qu'elles disent et il ya il ya
plein de choses qui n'avaient jamais été
dit et c'est très bien
vois-tu rien venir tourner violent et
c'est comme dans toutes les révolutions
les les révolutions sont faites à
certains moments par des gens qui se
déplie minorité qui sortent tout d'un
coup des choses qu'on a qui veulent
qu'ils veulent que ça change
mais ça va mettre du temps comment dire
et ça fait des dégâts therrien et savard
dégâts avec les aigles à ckoi c'est par
exemple quand j'entends les hommes
monfils l'autre jour qu'à 57 ans qui me
dit plein c'est dur de monter dans un
ascenseur avec une nana tout seul je
suis l'évolution raconte wild et tu sais
pas où regarder
gili aventure et comment il dit quand tu
entends tout ce qui se passe
toutes ces femmes qui sont harcelés qui
se disent qu'ils disent si affreux à
vivre et tout est bien ou c'est plus
pareil
il me racontait une lime à ma fille il a
une petite fille il dit les copines de
ma fille qui vivait viennent dormir à la
maison les soirées pyjamas et tout ça me
suis pas à l'aise parce que je pense à
tout ce qu'elle était
ce néo féminisme faudrait surtout pas
qu'on n'est pas les hommes dans notre
poche
moi j'ai toujours eu les hommes dans ma
poche fait tu sais j'ai jamais blacks et
les mecs parce que il faut faire avec
le tout alors là c'est une leçon de
mamie goron le tout c'est au départ de
choisir le bon mec
mais le son de ma guilde migros est trop
jeune fois de vieilles c'est celle de
hongrie avec ma copine avec votre copine
à bin voila et qui est beaucoup plus
jeune que moi alors on n'a pas le temps
parce qu'il ya des quizz formidable
notre fils est de la partie ce qui a
disparu à cause aussi
voilà ça s'appelle toujours merci et bon
[Musique]